hello i'm luis alvarez i am the
president of pity for europe middle east
africa latin america and talking about
what keeps me really motivated probably
there are two things the first one is I
feel an exciting experiment form a trio
where everybody is talking about new
investments new opportunities company's
coming here to grow the businesses
because of the growth of the middle
class and they increase investment from
governments and for private companies
the second thing that keeps me really
motivated is the willingness to make a
transformation in the society clearly
driving this social transformation using
both new infrastructures education
health and technology I'm firm believer
that the technology can really make a
change it's an enabler of the physical
infrastructure hospitals airports who
never work properly we have the right
technology but at the same time they
will leverage the human capital that we
have in the region so I am really really
excited about this opportunity and this
whole keeps me really motivated